hello everyone so far I've only shown
you games that bent Larsen lost but here
is a very interesting game he played
against Evan Geller it was played in
1960 it was the names of each Memorial
and I couldn't really find any
information about this tournament
other than bent Larsen an effing Geller
I have no idea who else played in this
tournament if any of you can find some
sort of link to this tournament feel
free to share it in the comments but
it's it's really a great game played by
the Danish Grandmaster and it's a very
ferocious attack so quite enjoyable and
the person he's playing against is the
Soviet Grandmaster Evan Geller who was
not only a world-class Grandmaster but
also a coach to Boris Spassky and later
Anatoly Karpov so quite a guy last game
you've seen bent Larsen play be three
against the Boris Spassky in this game
each Larson chooses the Hungarian
opening g3 we have d5 Bishop to g2 and E
5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 by Geller
even though efore is perfectly fine for
black but he decides to go for Knight to
c6 Larson castles we have Knight to f6
c4 d 4 @ b3 Bishop to d6 and Knight 283
going for night to see to rugby 1 and
expanding on the Queen side and grabbing
this night with the bishop doesn't
really give black anything well he loses
the bishop pair and white will simply
get a freebie file for his rook
so gellar castles we have work to be 1
continuing with this plan rook to e8 no
Knight the C to a5 preventing b4
but first Larson plays b3 you don't want
to play a move like a 3 to prepare
before because well a 4 stops any hopes
of be forever being played so after a5
Larson first place b3 we have h6 now he
plays a3 preparing B for a bishop to f5
and he pushes before a capture somebody
for a capture some before and Queen to
d7 preparing ideas like Bishop to h3
exchanging this light square bishop and
then what
probably attacking on the kingside be $5
goes 4/9 to d8 and already Larsen
created this beautiful pawn chain here
we have e 3d captures on e3 knife
captures on e3 attacking that bishop and
the bishop to h7 keeping keeping an eye
on this d3 pawn Bishop to b2
we have c6 trying to break break open
that pawn chain and our rook to a one as
this Knight is blocking drugs are not
connected so Gellar decides to capture
the rook rook captures an a1 Queen
captures on a1 with an attack on this
pawn on e5 but the killer first place C
captures on b5 we have Knight captures
on e5 with a temple on the Queen and
Queen to c7 playing a move like Bishop
captures on e5 and Bishop captures on e5
you still can't undo on switch C CAP be
captures on c4 because their Knight is
attacked White is still threatening
Bishop captures on f6 so after 95 Geller
decided to go for Queen to c7 we have a
night back to f3 Bishop to e7 now and
rook to c1 be captures on c4 d captures
on c4 and we have a Queen to b6 Knight
to d5 attack in both Queen and the
bishop on e7 so Knight captures on d5 C
captures on d5 and we have Bishop to f8
as this g7 pawn was attacked
we have Bishop to b4 improving the
position of this Bishop would a temple
on the Queen Queen to b3 and now Knight
to e5 and a Larson's plan is pretty
clear he wants to play Knight to d7
undermine this Bishop on f8 and then
grab this g7 pawn so we have b5 and
Knight to d7 and here there's a really
no way to protect the bishop because
well know no peace can protect it and
well probably the best idea for black
here is to play a move like f6 but after
Knight captures an f-18 captures on f8
the rope the ca for example this would
be extremely passive for black to play
but it would be playable better than
better than what Geller went for so
after Knight to d7 Geller tried Bishop
to e3 now gaining a tempo on this rook
and c1 and he thought well after y2
deals with this threat of me grabbing
the rook I'll deal with g7 after that
but Larsen says well you can have the
rook and he plays Bishop captures on g7
and if you look at this position well
capturing the rock and f1 isn't a
particularly good move but it's the only
move any other move loses instantly to
tonight f6 check so Bishop captures on
c1 is played Knight to f6 now King
captures on g7 and Knight captures rook
on ei twit check and well you definitely
don't want to go to g8 because then
Quinta ji-sun would be checkmate and if
you play a move like King to g6 well
this is also a very quick checkmate
for example Queen to g7 check King to h5
and now Knight to f6 and this is
checkmate
so after night to e8 check this is a
double check from the knight and the
Queen only move is King to f8 now Larson
place into a cheat with check and okay
maybe Bishop to g8 would be somewhat of
a more resilient move but King to e7 was
played we have b6 now would check Knight
is protecting pawn on d6 and well if you
play something like King to e6 will you
get Queen to f6 with check
a king to d7 now Queen to e7 with check
King to c8 and Queen to c7 checkmate
so after d6 gellar play King to d7
we have Knight to f6 with check King to
c8 where ever the light King goes well
it's it's not a really good position for
black so Gilardi cites at least he's
gonna try and protect this night on d8
but Larsson goes for Bishop to h3 check
acting to b7 and Queen captures on the
8th and well there is no move left
forget her to play he has one more check
Queen to D 1 check King to g2 and well
this is completely reasonable but Geller
tries one more last minute trickery and
he plays Bishop to d3 the idea of Bishop
to d3 is a pretty pretty sneaky one for
example if if white were to blunder I
would a slow move like Knight to d7 and
then Geller would have checkmate in two
moves with Bishop to f1 check a queen is
covering f3 into g1 and Bishop captures
and h3 with checkmate
but Larsson didn't play a great attack
like this the blunder in the last minute
so after Bishop to d3 Bishop the CH
check was played King to a 8 and now
Queen to a5 with check and in this
position F in Geller resigned the game
because what follows is going to be 820
see 7 check on the move s came to 8 and
not mean to b7 with checkmate so there
it is the first win by the Danish
Grandmaster on my channel sorry it took
so long I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said if you have any additional
information on this 1960 names of each
Memorial feel free to share it in the
comments as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon